trois jours de répétition son éclairage
placement tout est travaillé sur la
scène de la batterie casse aux jeunes
artistes guyancourt toit pour son album
de paris à maurice
[Musique]
c'est exactement moi je suis né à paris
de parents d'origine en régime
c'est pas spécialement mon histoire
c'est des thèmes qui me sont des thèmes
qui nous tiennent à coeur
c'est elle qui me tiennent à coeur de
thèmes qui sont qui sont là pour faire
avancer des tels qu'ils sont là pour
faire réfléchir
il ya un peu de tout ce seront la vague
selon moi mais les sorties
le 11 novembre dernier donc ça va alors
que je vais défendre sur scène donc pour
le défendre
du coup la balle on s'entraîne ici avec
les musiciens entrée par le show enfin
pouvoir représenter pas le meilleur show
possible des artistes locaux mais aussi
nationaux et internationaux
en dix ans la batterie en a accueilli de
nombreux comme le staff benda bilili
yodelice ou encore charles et les
coutures au mois de janvier au mois de
septembre lorsqu'il n'y a pas de concert
dans le cadre de nos résidences on met
systématiquement à disposition le
personnel technique de la batterie qui
soit et dans ce qu'on appelle du
baby-sitting quand les artistes ont leur
propres ingénieurs du son ou
éclairagiste donc nos techniciens
veillent à ce que tout se passe bien
techniquement pour les accueillir et
parfois les artistes n'ont pas forcément
encore constitué dans leur équipe
technique donc là ce sont les
techniciens de la batterie qui sont à
disposition des mauriciens qui sauront
viendra lui à la batterie à la rentrée
2010 est cette fois ci face au public